So, all of this conversation
just got me thinking.
It would be so much simpler if the off
variable just had the email embedded it,
instead of limiting us to just
having the UID of the provider.
I've heard about custom tokens,
not really sure what they are.
Can I use that to my
advantage in some way?
>> Yeah,
that would solve a lot of this problem.
>> Cool.
>> Yeah,
if only I had told you that sooner.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, no,
what you would do is you would need to
mint a custom token, as it's called.
And essentially, what that means is,
we have all kinds of libraries that you
can use on a trusted environment, so
that you don't ude on
the Android device of the user.
But you can run them on pretty
much any server environment or
any other trusted environment.
Essentially, you'd get to encode
whatever information you want and
you sign it with the secret
of your fire base and
you then use that as the off
variable in your security rules.
And that means that you can put
any information you want in there.
So if you've already verified the user's
email address, for example, you can just
put it in there and then in your
security rules you can say auth.email
and use it directly instead of having
to load it from your mapping table.
>> That actually sounds pretty awesome.
Are there, so this seems like something
that people probably do fairly commonly.
Are there any sort of prepackaged or
third-party options or
options that you would suggest
that already could get me up and
running with creating
custom tokens quickly.
>> Yeah, definitely, so for custom
tokens, typically if you have your own
existing user table then you need
to start making your own tokens.
But if you want to integrate with all
kinds of existing like social providers
like to Google or Facebook but also,
provider's firebase doesn't
support like Linked In.
And then you could choose Alt zero and
date.
Essentially, means
the question taken for you and
provide a lot more information to
the author board that you can use.
>> Okay.
Cool.
So basically what I'm hearing, is that
I could run a tiny bit of server code
on even my own Android phone, but will
probably somewhere better than that.
And then that would verify that
the users are actually own the email
addresses that they say that they own.
And that I could use a service
like auth zero to then attach
that email address to the off token and
easily use it throughout my rules.
>> Yeah.
>> Well Puff that sounds like a plan.
So, thanks for
taking the time to talk to us today,
I'm sure you have important
things to get to at Google.
The funny thing is,
that before we started talking I
really was not a security believer, I
didn't think it was that big of a deal.
But what I'm realizing is
that security is something
that you need to be thinking about even
at the stage that you're thinking about
how your data is going to be organized,
and it's super important to get right.
So, thank you so much for
showing me that.
>> No, thanks for
allowing me to explain this,
because indeed security is
very important with Firebase.
Right when you start data modeling,
as you say,
you must also figure out how you
want to secure the database.
Because if you don't, you never know who
you can trust in this world, do you?
[SOUND]